hi my name is kelani i'm nine years old
and today i'm gonna have two chefs
competing to make my drink dish
[Music]
hi kelani hi i'm alex i'm alexis hi so
kelani what would mummies eat
maybe something with bugs like like a
plate with like rainbow bugs this is the
scorpions
they have long tails
what are some of your favorite flavors
i like strawberry chocolate vanilla
i'm actually excited that she likes
fruity flavors and chocolate and vanilla
i'm definitely gonna go with a sweet
dish this time and then so these are the
spiders yes lots of legs on those
spiders okay she's saying scorpions and
spiders and
how am i gonna make a scorpion what else
is on the plate sticks sticks sticks
like this the main meal
is and these are the sticks yes so the
mummies like to eat sticks yes
like brown old sticks yeah and then
little ants oh it's on the stick these
are the llama eyes at the side my eyes i
love that there's llamas yeah the
mummies
these are like peruvians
here i know about monks they live in the
desert and they're dead i'm gonna use
all these blues
and make like a
huge like dip when you say dip
like like tears dip from the llamas cry
good good good good good good good
i have no idea this is a filling for the
eyes
and it's going to be like strawberry
okay lonnie do you think we can make
your mommy's dish yes yes you do yes
thank you so confident i think we can uh
wrap this up
so here's my plan for the sticks i'm
gonna make a chocolate bark out of
pretzels and coconut and i'm gonna put
little sprinkles on top for ants for
these scorpions and spiders i'm gonna be
making the bodies out of oreo truffles
and coating them in candy melts for the
colors for the llama eyes i'm gonna be
making strawberry cupcakes with a
strawberry icing and a strawberry in the
middle
and for the loma tears i'm going to be
making a blueberry flavored whipped
cream and coloring it blue and green
for the branch i'm going to use rice
krispie treats to make some whimsical
branch and then i'm going to cover it
with melted chocolate then for the
insects and the llama eyes i'm also
going to make little rounds of rice
krispies treats and cover them with a
marshmallow fondant and then i'm going
to add lots of fruit maybe some
chocolate covered blueberries some
sprinkles it'll be
imaginative i'm going to start by
getting my cupcakes in so they have time
to bake i am using just a basic yellow
cake mix
but i'm going to add some strawberry jam
to that to give it a strawberry flavor
because she said she really loves
strawberry
so i'm going to hit her over the head
with a strawberry rice krispie treats
are really easy to make i'm going to
melt the butter add the marshmallows
stir it down until it's nice and smooth
i've never dyed cupcakes purple before i
do know that when they bake color kind
of fades but i'm gonna just go with it
yeah yeah these marshmallows are almost
at the right consistency
marshmallows purple cupcakes done wow
we're so in unison just right into my
greased cupcake tin
yum
i didn't want to fill them too full
because they will cuff up
so i'm going to pop these in the oven at
350 to bake and then
we'll move on i'm gonna oh i'm gonna try
to shape these into a whimsical branch
but um
okay this feels like a whimsical branch
is not gonna happen these rice krispies
treats are not turning out the way i
thought they would be next i'm gonna
move on to making my truffles
for
the bugs it's a two ingredient
cookies and cream truffle all they take
are oreos and cream cheese i'm gonna
grind up the oreos and get it to a nice
fine powder
oh
let's forget these things
does it go other ways
i use food processors almost every day
of my life and i have never had such
trouble then i've had today
what is happening i think we need to
know how many people does he fail
okay wait
okay wait as alex was struggling this is
firming up so whimsical branch might
happen
stay tuned
oh my god oh my god
wait i gotta trick
oh my god i almost just died and came
back as a mummy
goodbye and good riddance
so actually while i was trying to help
alex the rice krispie treat um started
to solidify a bit so i can actually mold
it now wow my vision that worked out
so now i'm going to add my cookie crumbs
to
some cream cheese now that i have gotten
this into like a paste kind of thing i'm
just going to start rolling them into
balls so this will be like the bodies of
each of my bugs okay i'm gonna go pop
these in the fridge so they can set and
then we'll move on
[Music]
i'm gonna make some llama eyes now that
my tree and llama eyes and insects are
made i'm going to go put this in freezer
no you have to walk like a mummy
so now i'm going to move on to my sticks
crush up some pretzels
cool
got my frozen oh yum rice krispies
whimsical treat whimsical treat it is it
is totally is so now i'm gonna melt the
chocolate and then pour it over the tree
so
she loves chocolate looks like tree
so now i'm gonna go grab the cupcakes
actually
oh wow
so i definitely over filled them a
little
but on the bright side the bright purple
side
they still got a lot of color so now i'm
gonna add
the pretzels to this melted chocolate
coconut sweetened coconut i'm just gonna
plop these down
what do you mean
like kind of like a chocolate bark thing
you know that's cool i don't know what
really qualifies as chocolate bark it's
usually just chocolate with some stuff
in it and hopefully the chocolate bark
looks like sticks because of all that
texture so my chocolate is silky and
smooth
just drizzle it first
this kind of looks like bark
it does yeah
so my candy melts are melted and now i'm
going to start coating my truffles in
their colors to make the
rainbow bugs
i'm gonna move on to my marshmallow
fondant which i have to be honest i
haven't made before
regular fondant is what you would find
on wedding cakes or a lot of cakes it's
like kind of sickly sweet so you have
marshmallows add
a little bit of water
and microwave
okay so my marshmallows
are totally melted
and then powdered sugar
stir so i'm just stirring until it
becomes really stiff
and all the powdered sugar gets kind of
absorbed into the marshmallow so i'm
just gonna break apart these pretzels to
make
some bug legs
oh this feels
wrong i'm kneading it and it feels too
soft but it's also kind of working so i
think i'm just gonna go with it i'm just
gonna flatten one out
so smooth look at that
okay and i'm just gonna try to stick
these legs into my truffles hopefully
this goes okay
so i'm running into a little bit of a
problem with these truffles because the
candy coating has set me putting the
legs into it is cracking
the coating i don't know how this is all
gonna turn out i'm gonna try to use a
skewer
instead and create a hole before i try
to shove the pretzel stick in
okay
bug one is done
i'm now gonna dye this one so i'm gonna
use just a drop of gel food coloring gel
food coloring is more intense color and
it's not as liquid so it's not going to
change the consistency as much as liquid
food coloring would i have these little
candy eyes
and i feel like they'll make the bugs
really come to life
that's that's really great so i'm not
totally sure if i'm doing this right
it's really malleable which makes it
really easy for me but typically i think
it should be a little stiffer
but it looks good the marshmallow
fondant is actually covering these
bugs really well it looks smooth they're
brightly colored i think she's gonna
love it okay
so i'm gonna start assembling my llama
eyes i'm gonna take out some of the
center and i'm just gonna pop that right
in there i'm gonna use the bottom of a
piping tip to cut out some eyes for the
llamas now i'm going to make the
frosting for the cupcakes this is cream
cheese and butter
softened
a little bit of vanilla this is powdered
sugar i pre-sifted so now i'm going to
add some more strawberry jam to this
blah my eyes this frosting is a little
bit loose so
i think i'm going to pop it in the
fridge before i frost the cupcake so it
can kind of firm up a little and so i'm
just putting little eyes on my little
rainbow blobs which are representative
of the bugs
finally
i'm at the end i'm going to do the
blue tears i uh
forgot
about that
i forgot the llama tears i always forget
something but it's like on the edge of
the drawing i can't imagine she's
actually gonna notice i'm gonna melt
some chocolate and then make some
chocolate covered blueberries i'm just
making whipped cream so i'm doing heavy
whipping cream a little sugar and some
vanilla um so my chocolate's melted so
i'm just going to toss some blueberries
in there and then put them on this
little sheet tray so now i'm going to
add some blueberry jam
[Music]
she said it tasted like blueberries wow
you were really wow we have such
different strategies last time i lost to
alexis because she went even bigger than
the drawing and i went pretty literal
this time
i'm going pretty literal so now i'm
going to color
this blue
and then i'm going to color this one
green okay okay i'm ready to play
okay what am i doing
it's okay you can still piece it back
together oh this was a dumb idea
the tree is breaking why did i do this i
should have put it down on a greased
parchment paper but sticks break right
it should be fine
yeah
sure it's fine
okay i have to be perfectly honest i
didn't actually think about what the
flavor was gonna be like if she was
gonna enjoy eating this really yeah
yeah why why did i do that it was so
you've come so far you're so cocky
it's a lesson honestly it looks kind of
weird i don't know it doesn't match the
drawing i'm i'm not feeling good looks
beautiful you did it thanks we did it
yeah
putting together my dish i'm actually
super proud it looks like her drawing i
just hope it all tastes good and that
she really loves it i went big it's
imaginative and it's rice krispie treats
it's chocolate it's fruit this may not
look like kelani's drawing but i hope
she really likes it
bring me my mommy dish
it just looks like the picture the
sticks look so good
that's hard
that doesn't sound good
that's good
[Music]
i like the chocolate filling
um
strawberry is my favorite she seems to
like it all so far so i've got some hope
now i'm going to try some of this
this is blueberry
[Music]
well in this like picture it's almost
like siam
this is not cyan this is darkly
cyan i don't even know what that is best
of luck alexis
this is huge
i feel like these the sticks whoever the
chef is know i like strawberries and
then the eyes i just see eyes everywhere
the only thing i don't see is the dip
remember earlier when i said that i hope
she wouldn't notice there were no llama
tears she noticed
okay
is this rice krispie treats
her phone is good
[Music]
i feel like everything's made out of
crispy treats
[Music]
rice krispies
they say there's no such thing as too
much of a good thing but when it comes
to rice krispies treats it's apparently
not true i don't like these
they don't have any flavor
do you not want to swallow that
[Music]
it's like mushy
and marshmallows melted the marshmallows
are not my favorite
hi kaylani
which one did you like better the
cupcakes or the rice krispie treats
i like the cupcake
yeah yeah you didn't have the sauce oh
can't win everything alex deserves it
hers was amazing chef alex since you're
the winner you get my dollars thank you
so much finally i've been raised from
the dead so well i'll be taking this to
my grave
get it like mommy
[Music]
you